[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHANE SNOW: I want to tell this
story of how General Andrew
Jackson was fresh off
his latest massacre when
he got the assignment to lead
an army of lawyers, whores,
Choctaw Braves, and black
guys to save America
from destruction, along
with a gang of pirates.
So, I was really
excited to say that,
but we should back up and
talk about the history.
In about 20 years after George
Washington had basically
stopped being president-- he
decided that he was only going
to do two terms--
the country was in a
little bit of trouble,
because King George III
and his son, who I call 4G,
decided that they wanted to pay
themselves back for the losses
that they had in the Revolution.
So, they lost a bunch of
money on this revolution,
they'd just been
fighting Napoleon,
so they sent a bunch of ships
to the East coast of America
just in international waters
to basically pirate goods
from American boats.
And anyone with
a British accent,
they would conscript
into the British Navy.
So, this was obviously
very annoying
to the new-found republic.
And so Thomas Jefferson, who
was president at the time,
he had a solution to this
problem, which was just
to ban all imports and exports,
which immediately destroyed
the economy.
Historians say this is maybe
one of the dumbest things
any president has ever done.
Thomas Jefferson was very
good at writing Declarations
of Independence, it
turns out not very good
at trade or
international affairs.
So, he destroys the economy,
and then we're out of money.
So, to deal with
that, he says, well,
let's privatize the
military now, so
get rid of the
military, all that money
goes back to the government,
and this turned out
to be a problem when the
British then invaded.
They burned down
the White House.
They sacked all these
cities up and down
the East coast from
Maryland to Virginia.
And meanwhile, all of these
American companies that
survived off of trading goods
and international shipments,
their goods rotted
on the wharfs,
and the economy was doing
terrible, basically.
People started starving.
Companies started
going out of business.
And the British were fine.
So, what happened basically is--
this has never happened in
America before or since,
but everyone basically
flipped out on each other,
and they took sides.
The Democratic Republicans
burned down the newspapers
of their Federalist rivals.
The Federalists were like,
let's join the British.
And so, it was a
horrible situation
that that happened just after
this new country had started.
And this is around the time
that King George III and 4G
said, hey, maybe we can
actually take this land back.
So the country is in shambles.
Everyone is mad at each other.
They're super broke now.
And they have no military.
And so they decided
to do it, basically.
So they looked at the
map, and they said,
hey, we've burned
down all these cities,
taken over most
of the East coast.
All we've got to do is sail
up the Mississippi River,
and we can push the
Americans into the Atlantic.
So, this is a it's
one of those things
that, in American
history class we
learn about the
Revolutionary War,
and we learn about the Civil
War, and there's like one line
that the history
teacher usually says,
and there was a war in 1812.
But this is the story of what
happened in the War of 1812.
The British decided
they were going
to push the Americans
into the Atlantic.
So, they had sacked
all of these cities,
the North was ready to
join the British already,
but there's one thing standing
in the way of this plan,
and it was a little town,
sort of a raucous town
at the mouth of the Mississippi
River called New Orleans.
So, this was the
spot that they had
to get past in order to
go up the Mississippi
and do the land invasion
to take over America.
So, while everyone
in the United States
were suffering from this poverty
that the import-export ban had
happened, and all these
people in all these cities
had been sacked, while
that was going on,
New Orleans was
during this big party.
This is actually a picture of me
and my friends in New Orleans.
I'm there on the
right-hand side.
I'm like a cop
from 1979, I think.
That was Halloween.
So, they're doing this while
everything else was happening.
And this is thanks
to some local heroes
known as the Pirate
Brothers Laffite.
So, this group of
pirate brothers
was keeping New Orleans
in this nonstop party.
These are them.
So this is Pierre Laffite.
He ran the blacksmith shop,
where they would smuggle goods
in and then distribute them
to the city of New Orleans,
lots of rum and fine silks and
rugs and all sorts of things.
There was Dominic
You Laffite, who
was the guy that would sail
around the Caribbean and pirate
boats and take the goods to
be smuggled into New Orleans.
And then there was sort of the
PR guy, the face of the Pirate
Brotherhood, Jean Laffite.
So, I know that
this is what he's
supposed to look like if we're
going with movies of pirates,
but when they make the
movie about the War of 1812,
this is who I want
playing Jean Laffite.
It's Ryan Gosling.
Anyway, Eric knows I'm
a big Ryan Gosling fan.
So, what was happening is these
pirate brothers were basically
keeping the city full of rum.
And the rule was that you
were actually legally allowed
to plunder any ship in
international waters
as long as your country
was at war with them.
So, the British,
when they started
plundering these American
boats, they weren't at war.
And then they declared
war, so then it was legal.
So, these pirate
brothers actually
didn't refer to
themselves as pirates.
They called themselves
captains and privateers,
because they sailed under
letters of mark of Cartegna,
which is a city-state that
was conveniently at war
with everyone.
So, they're at war with
everyone so they could legally
plunder these boats.
But then the problem was getting
the goods from the ocean,
basically from the
Caribbean, to New Orleans.
It required them
to import stuff,
which was illegal at the time.
So, what they would do,
they had this little
set of islands that they would
basically dock their ships at,
and then they would row the
goods through the swamps.
And they would mysteriously
appear in New Orleans,
and everyone was having a good
time partying, drinking rum.
So, this is going
on while the British
are taking over America.
And as long as the pirates
kept the city in rum,
they left them alone.
So they sort of turned
a blind eye to this.
But Jean Laffite, being
the smart and handsome man
that he was, he was
stockpiling cannons
and flints and tinders just in
case they ever came for him.
So, the British army assembled
this enormous armada,
the largest armada ever
to set sail to sea.
They had just defeated
Napoleon, so they're feeling
pretty confident about this.
And they took a look at
the map, and they said,
well, we have to
get up the twisting
curves of the
Mississippi River, and we
have to knock out the New
Orleans defense, basically,
if we want to make
this plan work.
So, they couldn't put
their ships up the river
very quickly, so they said,
let's do a ground invasion.
We'll knock out the defenses.
Then we'll sail
our ships up, which
meant that they would have
to go through the swamp
and sneak-attack the
city of New Orleans.
So the British have about 20,000
troops and all of these ships.
So, they park the ships
outside of New Orleans,
ready to put the troops and
sneakily get through the swamp
to take over New Orleans.
And that's around the
time that the colonel
of the British troops,
the he that's in here--
Colonel Nichols was his name--
he paid a visit to Jean
Laffite and apparently his dog
and offered him
$2 million to help
them sneak through the swamp
so they could surprise-attack
the city of New Orleans.
And John Laffite,
being a pirate,
said, yeah, sure,
I'll take your money.
And then they went back to
the armada ready to get ready
for the surprise-attack,
and Jean Laffite immediately
double-crossed them,
because he was a pirate.
So he went, and he
told the government
of New Orleans
immediately this plan,
that the British were going to
sneak-invade, which obviously
everyone freaked out about.
But this was interesting timing,
because the state government
had just declared
war on the pirates.
So, the state was upset
that the pirates were
doing these illegal imports and
that the city of New Orleans
wasn't doing anything.
So, the governor had just
barely declared a $500 reward
for the capture of Jean Laffite.
And Jean Laffite,
being cocky and sexy,
posted up handbills all around
the state for a $5,000 reward
for the capture of
Governor Claiborne.
So, this pissed
off the government,
and so they sent a
crew to basically raid
their little pirate
island where they
were importing all this stuff.
I'm going to get to
the point of this soon.
But at the same time they were
double-crossing the British,
all the Pirates were
hiding their shit
in the swamp from
the government.
And what happened
around this time
is Pierre Laffite had
actually been captured.
He'd been arrested as part
of this government raid.
He mysteriously escaped
from prison around the time
that John Laffite
told the government
about this British plan.
So, you can kind of
see what's going on.
He traded the information
for his brother's release,
and then the
pirates disappeared.
So they said, hey, the
British are coming--
we're out.
Hid all their
stuff in the swamp.
So, the new president
of the United States,
Madison, freaked out, because
the country is going down
the tubes, the British
are going to take over.
And they had no army.
There's no military.
There's only one
person he could call,
and this was a little-known
militia commander, who
had been busy basically
harassing and murdering
Native Americans and clearing
out Tennessee for the settlers,
basically, a
controversial figure
named Andrew Jackson,
who, like the pirates,
was also a complicated fellow.
He had recently attempted
to kill his own governor
for some slight, some
insult. And he had just
massacred a bunch of natives
and, in a strange twist,
adopted an American-Indian baby.
Very complicated, strange guy.
And "strange" is the
right word to use for him.
And he was called to go
lead some sort of defense
of the city of New Orleans.
And he was nursing
a bullet wound
at the time when he
got the call, because--
this story is crazy.
He'd been shot after trying
to horsewhip some dude--
I had to put it up there
so I could remember--
who had gotten mad when his
friend shot that dude's friend
in the butt.
We can go over
this again to make
sure the sequence is clear.
A guy mooned Andrew
Jackson's buddy,
so Andrew Jackson's buddy
shot him in the butt.
And that guy's friend got mad.
Makes sense.
So Jackson then horsewhipped
that guy for being mad.
And that guy shot
Jackson in the arm.
So anyway, Andrew
Jackson shows up
to the city of New Orleans
with his arm in a sling
and diarrhea, because he has
dysentery from the journey,
I guess, in those days.
I don't really know
how to spell dysentery.
No one does.
So he shows up, and the
situation is not good,
because all they have to defend
the city from these 20,000
British troops are 200 local
businessmen, a contingent
of feisty, local whores who
had signed up for ammo duty.
And he brought with him
1,800 Tennessee hunters.
They call them Dirty Shirts.
These guys had never
really fought a war,
but they were hunters with
these long, slow rifles that
had been part of these
Indian skirmishes.
There was also a platoon
of freemen of color
who hadn't been paid
in a while, but they
were part of a local militia
that had been disbanded.
And he offered to pay
them if they joined up.
There's a crew of Choctaw
Braves, 62 American Indian
Braves who for some reason
were willing to help this guy
and these people who had
been treating them badly.
And Andrew Jackson
promised to pay them.
And he gave this rousing
speech, where he said,
I know we have our
differences, but let's
set aside those
differences for a second,
and let's save the city
and maybe the country
from these people that want
to invade our homeland.
So he gave this speech,
and everyone cheered.
And then he went
back to his room,
and he shit himself because
of the dysentery and also
because the British had this
enormous army against his 3,000
misfits, none of whom had
ever fought a war before,
like a real war.
And so he knows that
this is a lost cause
and that he's going to die
and all of these people,
who he just convinced
to defend the city,
are also going to die.
And he knew what had happened in
these cities on the East Coast
that had been sacked
and pillaged and burned
and what the soldiers
did to the families
and the women of these
soldiers that they'd killed.
And everyone was rightly
freaked out by this.
So around this time, Andrew
Jackson, with his dysentery,
gets a visit from a lawyer, a
guy named Edward Livingston,
who was kind of like the
Saul Goodman of those days,
if anyone knows Saul Goodman.
This guy shows up,
and he says, there's
another group of people
who could potentially
join your army.
He says, who?
He says, well, is Jean
Laffite and his merry band
of privateers.
Look at this good-looking guy.
And Andrew Jackson says, no,
I don't deal with pirates.
Are you kidding?
They're criminals.
We're not going to do this.
Saul Goodman says, well,
they have a bunch of cannons.
He says, actually,
yes, OK, bring them on.
So Jean Laffite becomes-- this
is why this should be a movie.
John Laffite becomes
a co-strategist
of the defense force.
So he and Andrew Jackson
become the generals
of this ragtag army.
So now Andrew Jackson-- if
I haven't made it clear,
I don't really like this guy.
He had a lot of
hate in his heart.
He hated Creoles,
which is basically
the Spanish and
French descendants,
the immigrant community
of New Orleans.
He hated pirates because
they were criminals.
He hated the American Indians.
He was not on the
right side of history
when it came to black people.
He was a slave owner.
And these were all the
people in his army.
But he said, I guess this
is more important for now
than my personal hatred for
all these people who are not
like me for whatever reason.
And thus was born the most
diverse army ever assembled
in the history of
the United States,
under-manned, outgunned,
but very, very
interesting ragtag group.
So I want to sit back and
talk for a second about teams.
Now, I'm here.
I'm going around to
Google and other places
to talk about this
book that I just
wrote that everyone who's
here gets a free copy.
So-- yeah, thanks.
I hope you enjoy it.
So, this is one of the
stories in the book.
It's about teamwork.
And it's about the lie we've
been told our whole lives when
it comes to working together
and it comes to teamwork.
And that lie is that two
heads are better than one.
Turns out that two heads are
usually not better than one.
And there's lots
of proof for this,
but despite that,
we won planet Earth
because we could band together.
We were smart enough.
We were equipped to collaborate.
So that's how we beat all
these crazy animals that were
much more ferocious than us.
We were smart enough to
work together to build fire,
to build civilization.
And so there's a reason that
dogs look up to us and love us
and they're not our master.
We can make a range
of vocal sounds
that they can't, so we can
communicate with each other.
Even things like the
whites of our eyes
are three times the size
of any other primates.
So when I'm looking
at something,
you can tell what
I'm looking at.
It makes it easier for us to
work on things, to collaborate,
even if we can't communicate.
And I was really
proud of this one.
This is a hipster and a gorilla.
Our brains are
equipped for empathy,
which means that we can mirror
the emotions of other people
that we encounter.
This is our brain's
way of helping
us to care about someone.
So when someone's in
trouble and they're
running away from the
saber tooth tiger,
we get adrenaline also.
Our heart rate
elevates so that we
can run with them or
we can fight with them.
And also, this empathy thing
helps us to love and care
about people, so we stick
together with our families
and so we stick together with
our tribes so we can survive.
There are all these reasons why
humans are built to collaborate
or were built to work together.
But it turns out that
collaborating is hard.
We say that synergy or
whatever, one plus one
can equal more than two.
Turns out that's
almost never true.
They did these experiments
where they asked people
to yell as loud as they could,
and they measured the decibels.
And when you're in a room by
yourself yelling as loud as you
can, you'll yell a little
bit louder than when you're
in a room full of six people.
And that was sort of strange.
They did these other
experiments where
they had people pull on a rope.
And it turns out that when
you're doing a tug of war
with a group of people,
you exert less force
on the rope, a little bit,
than you do by yourself.
Even if you're like
this kid and you think
you're pulling your hardest.
And some people will say,
well, this is social loafing.
Someone on the tug-of-war rope
or someone in the yelling room
is slacking off because
of the group, which
happens, definitely happens.
Some of this might
be coordination.
You have a lot of people,
coordinating is hard.
The only cliche more
common I think in business
than synergy is how long it
takes to turn a battleship,
right?
You have a lot of people, a big
organization is hard to change.
It's slow.
But there's other
stuff that happens
that's psychological when humans
come together to work together.
This is my favorite
series of stock photos.
I like to call it "White Guy
Leads Brainstorm Session."
So, it turns out that
over and over again,
when researchers put people
in rooms or around a table
to brainstorm ideas, a
group of the same people,
just as smart or the
same actual people,
will come up with fewer ideas
and fewer good ideas together
in the same room than
they will on their own
and then if they just add
up their lists of ideas.
And they've shown this so often
that one famous psychologist
said that "business people must
be insane to use brainstorming
exercises."
My favorite, one
of their colleagues
said that something
like, as surely
as cigarettes lead
to lung cancer,
brainstorming in groups leads
to not as good of ideas.
So this is sort of depressing.
And there's lots
of reasons for it,
our need to fit into the group.
Sometimes it's unsafe to
express certain ideas that
might come to us
when we're alone,
when there's a group dynamic.
Whatever it is, we see this
phenomenon over and over
and over again that when
we put our heads together,
we usually don't add up to more.
Maybe we add up to just
as much, but we certainly
don't add up to more.
And then there's
the other thing that
happens when groups
come together,
is we have differences.
So we get in each other's faces.
Our different opinions cause
us to fight, to have conflict.
Sometimes we even
try to destroy--
this is my second "It's Always
Sunny" slide, for anyone that's
a fan of the show.
Sometimes we try to destroy each
other when we come together.
But the reality is that we
can't build anything big
without more than one person.
You can't make Google
with one person.
That's why we're
all here, right?
You can't build a
building by yourself.
You can do a heart
surgery by yourself.
You can't even clean
the stadium in time
for the next game
with one person.
So we endure this
loss of productivity
that comes with group work.
We endure these squabbles
and these fights
and the jerks that
try and foil us.
And then we put up walls
against each other.
We say, we don't want
to listen to you.
We try and put our rivals
and our critics on the floor.
And we beat our
plowshares into swords,
and we turn nuclear energy,
this wonderful potential power,
into a bomb.
And the very same thing
leads to all of this.
It's the differences
we have between us.
And yet, some teams actually
do manage to feel magical.
And maybe some of you have
felt this way when you've
worked together in groups or
you've been part of something
where it feels like
whatever you're up to,
you can do the impossible.
You feel infinite.
And sometimes the team
that isn't supposed to win
overcomes the odds,
and they do win.
Anyone that's had a family
knows that sometimes
with human beings, one plus
one can equal more than two,
literally.
And so this is how
every great movement,
every great breakthrough
in history of society
has come about, is when
different humans came together,
and they worked together.
They linked arms, and
they overcame the odds.
And this is important,
because this
what we're trying to do,
not just in our work,
but in general, as we're
part of the team of humans
that owns this planet now.
But the reality is, when
humans come together,
we either break down
or we break through.
And the thing that leads
to both of those things
is kind of the same thing.
It's the subtle interactions
between our different ways
of thinking.
So this is the thing
that I've been obsessed
with over the last
many years, as someone
who is covering innovation
for magazines like "Wired"
and then starting my own company
and realizing that we needed
to work together better if
we wanted to break through
instead of breaking down.
And it turns out
that there is math
behind this paradox of
synergy, or the lack
thereof, that those
groups that do
feel infinite that
do add up to more,
they have something
going for them
that has actually been proven
out in mathematical models.
And so to explain this--
and I promise I'll get back
to the pirate story--
join me at a dinner
party where you've
baked this delicious
chocolate cake for dessert
for your eight best friends.
And it's a delicious
round cake, and you
need to cut it into
eight equal slices.
So, everyone kind of knows
how to do this, right?
But pretend for whatever
reason the knife you're using
is enchanted.
It's a magic party
for some reason.
And it's going to disappear
after you make three cuts.
So how do you make eight
slices of cake with three cuts?
Now, some people will instantly
know the answer to this,
but most people, and me
included, will do this.
They'll take the cake by cutting
it in half like a pizza, cut
in half again.
And then when you realize
that you're out of cuts,
your third cut, if you had just
one more, you could make eight.
Third and final cut only
makes six slices of cake,
and two of your friends know you
love them more than the others.
So how do you solve this puzzle?
How do you make three cuts
to make eight slices of cake?
Someone--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SHANE SNOW: The z--
yeah.
Yep.
So, some people will
immediately see this.
Some people say, well, you could
do some curvy S calculus cuts.
Can't do that, because your
friends need to know you
love them equally.
So what you do is you cut it
in half, cut it in half again,
and then you literally
turn the problem
on its side, the z-axis, and
you cut it all the way through.
Now, some of your friends
get less frosting this way,
but if we pretend there's
frosting in the middle,
then maybe they all
know you love them.
I like to say that if you
give this puzzle to a kid,
they might actually have
an easier time getting it,
because they're this
high off the ground
and they look at the
cake from this level.
But all it takes is
turning the problem around
to see that there's
a solution to it that
makes eight slices of cake.
So, this is a
literal, fun example
of what I call one
half of our mental tool
kit, which is perspective.
So when psychologists
talk about perspective
and neuroscientists, they
say that it is the way
that we encode what we
encounter in the world
into our own internal language.
So inside of our brains,
we process things,
and we internalize them in
our own little programming
language.
And everyone's is a
little bit different,
but there are lots
of things that
can help us to form similar
perspectives or not,
so everything from
where you grew up,
generation you grew
up in, who you are,
how you identify,
to the stories,
the experiences you've
had in your life.
So, if we're walking
down the street
and there's a building on fire,
if you've been in a burning
building before, you're going
to encode that situation
in a different
perspective then if you're
a firefighter than me, who
I've never had anything
to do with fire.
So the things we've been
through in our lives
help us form perspective.
If I would hazard a guess
based on you saying the z-axis,
probably something in your life
or training or whatever it is
leads you to have that 3D
graph mentality in your head.
I don't know.
Are you an engineer
or mathematician or--?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SHANE SNOW: 3D CAD systems.
Yeah, exactly.
So you are used to looking
at physical problems
literally from
three-dimensional perspectives.
So there's lots of
things that form this.
We all kind of know this.
There's a second half
of our mental toolkit
that we'll go back to our party
and we'll talk about this.
So, you have three
glasses of milk
and three empty glasses
at this cake party.
And the challenge,
for whatever reason,
the puzzle is you need to
alternate these glasses so they
go full, empty,
full, empty, full,
empty so no two full glasses
are next to each other.
Now, how do you do this
if, for whatever reason,
again, magic, you can
only move one glass?
And once again, some people
will instantly know the answer,
and some people
will take a while.
And if you're like me,
you think it's impossible.
So, most people will
take the second glass,
and they'll move it in
between these two glasses.
And then you realize that
you had one more move,
you could do this.
So, most people will take
this and then move it here.
There's still two glasses
next to each other.
Does anyone have the answer?
Anyone know how you
can move one glass
and alternate them full, empty?
Were you raising your hand?
No?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SHANE SNOW: Yes, so you
take the second glass,
and you pour it into
the second-to-last one,
and then you put it down.
You've only moved one glass.
Now, I want to ask
people this question,
and they don't get
it if I tell them,
pretend that you just
got home from your job,
your day job as a chemist.
Most people will
then get the answer,
because you realize
a chemist, their job
is to pour things in and
out of beakers, I think.
That's what we think of
when we think of a chemist.
But this is called-- the
solution to this puzzle
is basically heuristics.
Heuristics are strategies,
approaches to solving
a problem, or rules of thumb.
There's lots of different
ways we refer to them.
But heuristics sometimes
are very connected
to our perspectives.
How we see something leads
us to develop a different way
to solve a problem or
approach a problem.
But often they're very detached.
So heuristics come from all
sorts of things, how you've
had to navigate life,
but also very much
comes down to your education
and, again, the experiences
that you've had, what
you've been invited
to do, what you've
been excluded from,
how you have to go
navigate the world.
My favorite example of this
that I wrote in the book
is when I talk about police
work, detective work.
Interviewed basically every
highest-ranking female officer
in law enforcement, so ATF, FBI,
bunch of homicide detectives.
And all of them
universally told me
something really
interesting, which
was-- because I had
the question of, why
are there so few women
in law enforcement
when statistics show that
women shoot people wrongfully
six times less than men
do in law enforcement?
So that's an
interesting question.
You can read about it in the
first chapter of the book.
But most of the
women I interviewed
said, well, if you grow up and
realize around middle school
that you have less upper-body
strength than the boys
in your class, then your
solution to physical problems
often is not the same
thing that they do.
So you encounter a locked door.
Instead of immediately
trying to see
if you can knock it
down or kick it open,
you actually resort
to potentially trying
to compromise
whoever has the key
or finding some way to negotiate
the opening of the door.
And this is not universal.
But in general, if you
grow up a certain way,
then you develop different kinds
of strategies for certain types
of situations.
And that's just one example.
But whatever it is
you've been through
can be relevant to looking at
a problem in a different way
or can be relevant
to approaching
a problem in a different way.
So the way this
all comes together
with the math of
synergy is like this.
You have this cartoon
mountain range,
which represents any problem
you're ever working on in life.
It can be represented
by a range of solutions.
So if we pretend that every
peak on this mountain range
represents a different
quality of solution--
the taller the peak, the
better the solution--
we can say any problem
you encounter in life
can be represented by this.
There's good solutions,
there's less good solutions.
And whenever we're
looking at a problem
or we're approaching
something, it's
like we're hiking around this
mountain range in the fog,
and you get to the top of a
peak, and you have to decide,
do we go downhill and
try and find another one,
or have we found a good one?
How do we navigate this?
So your perspective
is basically where you
get dropped on the mount range.
So let's pretend this is me.
I get dropped off here.
You go uphill at first.
You look for the closest
solution to the problem.
And then my heuristic is
basically what I do next.
So I grew up in Idaho.
Let's pretend that in Idaho
in mountain-climbing school,
they say the rule
of thumb is when
you get to the top of the peak,
you go down the other side,
and you walk 50 paces.
And if it starts going uphill
by then, then you keep going.
And if it doesn't,
then you retreat back
to the mountain peak you're on.
You're probably in
a pretty good spot.
So my heuristic, basically
I go down 50 paces.
I say, nope, it's still fog.
It's going downhill,
probably have a good solution
to this problem.
So you can see I haven't ended
up on a very good solution,
but it is a solution to
whatever the problem is.
Now, say someone on my team
has a similar perspective.
She gets dropped
off on the mountain.
She's looking at it
from the same way.
We've worked together
for a long time,
whatever the reason for us
having a similar perspective.
But she has a
different heuristic.
She went to a different
mountain-climbing school
than me.
And so she goes
uphill, and heuristic
is you get to the top
of the mountain peak,
go over to the other
side, and you hike down
until you get to the trough
between two mountains.
And then you look and you say,
which way goes up steeper?
Whatever way that is, you go.
So she gets down here.
She says, this way is steeper.
She goes up here.
She gets to here, says,
nope, it's not as steep.
I found a better
solution to the problem.
Now, how teamwork usually
works is if we're a good team,
then she'll yell down, and
she'll say, hey, Shane,
I found a better
solution to the problem.
Yay, teamwork.
We got somewhere.
And this is where that
two heads are better
than one thing comes into play.
It turns out that
this group is only
going to be as smart as the
smartest person in this group
or the person who
has the right tool
kit, right combination of
perspective in heuristic
to get the furthest.
And then the rest of
the group follows.
And this is where we get
things like best practices.
So we find a solution
to whatever problem
it is that's good.
And then we say, this is it.
This is the way to do it.
We all start with
this perspective,
and we all solve it this way.
But little do we know,
there is a better solution
out there that we
just can't get to.
And in fact, our success leads
to this cognitive entrenchment,
where we can't actually
see anything else.
And maybe sometimes an
earthquake has happened.
The world has changed.
There's a new mountain
that we don't see.
And disruption is
basically when someone else
finds that and leaves us on
this lower mountain peak.
So, how the math
of synergy works
is someone with a
different perspective
is like someone who
gets dropped off
on a different part
of the mountain range.
And then this dude
with the hat, however
he navigates with his
perspective and heuristic,
he's going to end up somewhere.
And literally in this
cartoon, this works out.
If we say, well, what if
we tried my way or her way,
the go down to the steep
part, from his point of view?
And if you do that, you actually
end up going the steep way.
And this is how
the whole group can
become smarter than any
one person in the group,
is when you combine
the perspectives
and the heuristics.
So this is what's called
cognitive diversity
in psychology.
Basically, the more different
perspectives and heuristics
we have for a
problem, the more we
can turn it around and
potentially find solutions
that are better than any group.
So two heads are
only better than one
if they have a diverse
combination of those things.
So where does cognitive
diversity come from?
Really, this cognitive mosaic
that we see the world through
and we navigate the world
through, it's our perspectives.
It's our heuristics.
It's something I call how
you roll, how we attack
the mountain, how we operate.
And this is all formed
by our life experiences,
the day-to-day
experiences we've had,
our education, our work,
places we've been and lived,
opportunities and exclusions
we've had, people we've met,
people who have helped
us on our journey.
This forms all of these things.
And this is where we start
to get into work culture
territory.
What forms these
life experiences?
Well, these are very much part
of our internal and external
attributes, who we are, age,
gender, race, orientation,
habits, parental status, you
grew up with parents or not.
All these things form our
life experiences, which
then form our cognitive mosaic.
Now, all of these
things are not going
to be relevant to every
problem, every mountain
range we work on.
But many of them
are, and we tend
to underestimate how these
different kinds of things
lead us to have different
ways of looking at problems.
So like I said, two heads
are only better than one
if those heads see things
differently enough.
And in the book, I
get deeper into kind
of these mathematical models
for how this works but mostly
through cartoon form.
But it only works if you
actually combine these things.
So, if you have people
with all this potential
to find the solution
of the problem
but you don't
listen to the person
with the other perspective on
the other side of the mountain
range, you say, la, la,
la, we're not listening,
then you're not
going to get there.
Or even worse, if
this person doesn't
feel like it's safe enough to
speak up about what they see
and how they see the
problem, or if they say,
hey we don't care what you say,
you need to fit the culture,
so get down off the mountain,
come over to this side
and climb up here.
This is the way we do things.
That's the death of problem
solving and innovation.
But this basically explains
kind of every problem
in corporate America.
So for any of this to
work, you don't just
need the different
cognitive mosaics.
You need cognitive
friction also,
which, if I can go
on another diversion,
this is not
coincidentally how we
got hip-hop, which is the thing
that Eric and I have bonded
over.
So, I moved to New York.
I grew up in Idaho.
I did not know why Notorious
BIG was so notorious.
I did not know how
to pronounce RZA.
I thought it was R,
Z, A. I could quote
every lyric to the song "Country
Girl, (Shake It For Me)"
and "Fishing in the Dark."
So I knew nothing about hip-hop.
So I love the story of hip-hop.
So forgive me if you know it.
How we got hip-hop is
basically this idea
of cognitive friction.
Started with these dance
parties in the Bronx,
where the party was
every weekend there would
be dance hall where
they'd have two deejays,
one DJ on one side, one
DJ on the other side.
And the game was
see which DJ can
get the party to dance on
their side of the dance hall.
So this was all about what
music you brought every week,
how loud your speakers were.
People would show up every
week, and they'd do this party.
And they'd pay money, and
then the DJs were all happy.
And after a while,
the DJs started
having these hype guys
announcing the next song.
They'd try to drag people over
to their side of the party.
And so they'd say,
hey, everybody,
my DJ's got this great song.
Come over here.
Come dance.
And then the MCs would start
getting really into it,
and they'd do these sort
of fun couplets, where
they'd be like--
forgive me anyone
who watches this.
They'd be like, hey, ho,
put your hands in the air,
come on, y'all, like
that sort of thing.
And one week, this
guy named Busy Bee,
who was sort of
everyone's favorite,
he was there hyping up his DJ.
And he goes, ba-ditty, bada,
bang, de bang, diggy-diggy,
put your hands in the air,
ya'll, that whole thing.
And this other guy, the
other DJs hype man, his name
was Kool Moe Dee, instead
of doing the same thing,
like, hey, ho, come on, he
says, now hold on, Busy Bee,
I don't mean to be bold, but
put that ba-ditty-ba bullshit
on hold.
And it was like,
[IMITATES RECORD SCRATCH]
like record scratch.
And everyone was like, what?
And then he goes
for five minutes
just with this rhyming
poetry, insulting Busy Bee
and his music and his DJ.
And everyone went nuts.
They thought it was the
greatest thing ever.
So then the next week-- you
imagine if that happens to you,
you don't show up the next week
saying, hey, ho, ba-ditty-ba.
You come prepared.
And this turned into this
weekly battle of wits.
And then it also turned into
this weekly battle of dance.
And you didn't show up every
week with the same stuff
as last week.
You showed up ready
for the battle.
And Jay-Z was actually on
Letterman's new Netflix show
recently talking about this.
And he said, you know,
this wasn't actually
about destroying each other.
It was all about the party.
We knew that this
competition, this battle
was about making
this party better.
We're all in on it.
You wanted to win, but
more people showed up,
we all made more money,
everyone made more--
Jay-Z was young
when this happened.
But that's what this is about.
But it got to the point
where the DJs started hacking
their equipment.
Grandmaster Flash soldered
on a little switch
into his record
player to fade down
the music so he could fade
up music on another record.
Everyone blew their minds.
Everyone then tried to do that.
When they started doing
electronic samples,
DJ's would actually
crack open the equipment
and add more memory so they
could do better samples
and beat the other guy.
And so out of this
competition, this friction,
was born not only hip-hop,
but all of the genres of music
that came after it, R&B and
whatever the hell dubstep is.
And also, actual innovation
in computers came from this.
And so this is again
kind of a literal example
of how innovation
is actually born
from the friction between the
different ways of our thinking.
You didn't show up
doing the same thing.
That would have been dumb.
But if it wasn't for this
competition, this battle
of wits, we wouldn't have got
hip-hop and all the things that
came with it.
So I kind of chart
out if you look
at potential energy
between a group of people,
you can sort of chart it like
this as like a rubber band.
The more you
stretch, the more you
put tension on a rubber band,
the more potential energy
it has.
Same thing with a group.
A group of people with different
perspectives and heuristics
are like people pulling
on a rubber band
from different sides.
Now we're all afraid
of the part where
the rubber band snaps, right?
It hurts.
But if we don't go
that far, then there's
a lot of potential.
You can shoot the rubber band
really far or whatever it is.
You can make a whole
industry that hip-hop made.
And anyone who knows
the history of hip-hop
knows that at some point
it actually did go too far.
Things got personal.
There's an East coast,
West coast thing.
People actually got murdered.
And the whole music industry
stepped back and said, well,
what are we doing this for?
What is this about?
Is this about elevating the
party, making better music?
Or is this about literally
trying to kill each other.
So this is what we're all
afraid of when we work together
with people who are
different than us,
is this tension, this friction,
which could lead to snapping
or could make it
an unsafe place.
But this is actually
the thing that
gives us all the
potential in the world,
combining our perspectives
and our heuristics,
which are shaped by our life
experiences and who we are.
This is how we get into
this zone of possibility.
And this is where
innovation happens.
So in a group of people,
if you're a leader,
you want to get the
group into this zone
of cognitive friction.
You want to push things out
of that destruction zone,
and you want to
depressurize things.
You want to prevent also
this inertia from happening,
where everyone gets
along too famously, where
all of our ideas, we all agree,
no one is willing to speak up
or to battle or be someone's
intellectual opponent.
And so the best leaders,
the best groups actually
try and push things into
this zone of possibility.
So I'm going to get
back to the pirate story
in like three minutes.
But the missing ingredient
for any of this to work--
it's great if you have
cognitive diversity.
It's great if you have friction.
But if you're not willing to
change or adapt because of it,
then what is it good for, right?
You can have an
argument, and then
if no one changes their
minds, what is it for?
So this thing called
intellectual humility, which
is the last few
chapters of my book,
get into this idea of
being able to transcend
your own way of thinking,
which is extremely hard,
it turns out, for
the human brain
to do once we've
become entrenched
in a way of doing something.
So, to get at that, I
want to tell a quick story
about these two guys.
They were two engineers
that were collaborating
about 100 years ago.
And if you walked by their
shop on any given day,
you'd hear them
yelling at each other.
Their assistants,
their neighbors
were really worried
that these guys
were going to punch
each other out or kill
each other at some point.
You walk by, and it's screaming,
yelling, arguing all the time.
But then if you'd walk by
their shop around lunchtime,
you'd hear nothing, like quiet.
But then after lunch, the
screaming, yelling would start.
Basically what
these guys would do
is they'd be working
on a problem,
they'd be trying to figure
out the solution to something,
and they'd purposely start
these really intense arguments,
where they'd take extreme sides
and really yell at each other.
But then at lunchtime,
they would stop,
they'd eat their
sandwiches, and then
they would switch
sides of the argument.
So one guy had to argue the
other guy's side and vice
versa.
And this forced them
to let go of their need
to be right, to detach their
ego from their intellect
in whatever this argument
was and forced them to use
a little bit of
intellectual humility
so they could amp up
this cognitive function,
they could have these
really intense debates.
But it didn't matter if
you lost, because you were
going to switch sides anyway.
So it was about pushing
that party forward.
And this might sound like
a hostile work environment,
if you think about yelling
at your coworkers all day.
But you'll forgive
them when you learn
that these are the two guys
that invented the airplane.
This is Orville
and Wilbur Wright.
And maybe they
could actually have
the fights be really intense
because they were brothers.
They knew that they were family.
They would be OK.
But they deliberately
did this because they
wanted to get to the
top of the mountain,
but they knew that when
you're ready to murder Wilbur,
you've got to switch sides.
You need to change.
So this is their little
trick for doing this,
for unlocking this equation.
So, moral of the
story is we need
to be able to change our
minds because of this stuff.
We need to value the friction.
We need to value the
cognitive diversity
if we want to get
anywhere further than we
can go on our own.
But we need to be able
to change to do it.
So this in a nutshell
explains all the reasons
corporate America
sucks and why we have
so many problems in the world.
And it's a starting
point for figuring out
how we can make our
teams and our communities
and societies better, actually
leaning into these things.
So speaking of impressive
teams, the British army
was fucking dope.
They had 20,000 troops
that just beat Napoleon.
And they figured
out pretty quickly
that Jean Laffite wasn't
going to show up to guide them
through the swamps.
So they're like, great,
our cover is blown.
But we have 7-1 odds against
these misfits in this party
city.
They're probably
all drunk anyway.
So, they rode their
boats through the swamp.
And they make camp right outside
of the city of New Orleans,
ready to just use like
a British-style ground
invasion, rows and rows
of thousands of soldiers
and their great outfits
to just overrun the city,
take over America.
So that night as
they're camped out,
they're getting ready for
this battle, a ship floats,
a pirate ship, in fact, floats
down the Mississippi River
and docks right off the
shore of this camp of 20,000
British soldiers.
And it stops.
And it waits.
And it does nothing.
And they fired some
warning shots at it.
And the British decided,
they're like, oh,
this little tiny ship, whatever.
It's probably a
fisherman or some idiot.
And so they go to bed.
They have their sentries
up, but they go to bed,
and they're watching it.
And then the pirate
ship opens fire,
just cannons after
cannons after cannons,
cannon balls into the camp.
They're not making
a dent on this army,
but it's really hard to sleep.
And they have to kind of
batten down, hide in the mud.
They get done with
all the cannonballs.
They start shooting cutlery and
random things into the camp.
And so this is very annoying
to the British army, obviously.
There's no way that
you're going to still win
7-1 odds with this going on.
But they're ruining their
sleep, really obnoxious.
And then meanwhile, anyone
who ran into the woods to pee
would run into this
guy and get tomahawked.
So these Choctaw Braves
were out there basically
murdering anyone who got
too far away from camp.
And they had taught their
rivals, the Dirty Shirt
Tennessee hunters,
had to climb trees
and to sit in the top of a
tree and assassinate anyone
who was a target, basically.
So the British thought this
was really unchivalrous.
Again, they're not making
a huge dent in the army,
but this is really
bad for morale.
They thought it was
really unchivalrous.
This is not how noble
wars are fought.
You're supposed to line up,
look each other in the eyes,
and do battle.
This is how war was done.
So Colonel Nichols, the
head of the British,
he sent an envoy to Jackson
that night to cordially
request that they meet
in the field of battle
and fight like men of honor.
And Jackson literally
said, go fuck yourself.
And he sent this
envoy back, and he was
like, you're invading my land.
Fuck you.
So in the morning, the
British, demoralized, tired,
their friends are being
murdered in the night when
they go to pee, everyone is
afraid to pee, they get up,
they line up.
They're like, OK,
we're going to do this.
So Jean Laffite and
the freemen of color
teamed up to build a
moat and a dirt rampart.
So they lined the city
with this rampart.
They built it out into the
swamp kind of strategically so
that you had to go
over this rampart.
It was only about this high.
But this was their
defense force.
And so the British, as they're
tromping through the mud,
they're coming up on this.
Now, this is how all
of the paintings show.
They're like, oh, Andrew
Jackson boldly there,
no one is shooting him.
When I make the
movie about this,
it's going to be Ryan Gosling,
which is who is really
up there manning the fort.
Anyway, so what happened
is the Dirty Shirt riflemen
were waiting in the trees
with their hunting rifles.
And then Jackson
issued everyone whiskey
supplied by the pirates
and the British charge.
So they line up, they charge,
the defenders open fire.
And it turned out
that the hunting
rifles that these Dirty Shirt
riflemen had were really slow.
They're not what you want
in this kind of battle.
But they can shoot way further
than the British muskets.
So they basically
just assassinated
all of the British leaders.
They all sat on horses.
They were very visible targets.
And you're not
supposed to do that.
Like you're not
They did it anyway.
And so the British come up.
And the worst part--
they were so obedient,
this army, that you're
supposed to take orders.
You don't do anything that's,
you know-- their core value was
like obedience to leadership.
And this one platoon of
Scotsmen, the 90-second Scots,
their captain yelled, halt!
And then he got assassinated.
And so they halted,
and they stayed
there until like 800
of them got shot.
Finally another captain came
in, and he was like, retreat!
And they're like, thank God.
And it's like this horrible kind
of case study of actually being
stuck on a mountain peak
that is not the optimal one,
even when probably some people
there could have spoke up
and said, we should
probably not halt right now.
Anyway, so the battle
was really awful.
But after the smoke cleared
from the first assault,
the British had lost 3,500
men, and the Americans
had lost 333, so 7-1
odds against them
but 10 to 1 casualties
in their favor.
The British realized this
is going to be way too hard.
We're not going to
make this happen.
So they went home.
And New Orleans threw a party.
And this is the
reason why we don't
have the queen on our $5
bill, is because of this.
And the party hasn't stopped,
by the way in New Orleans,
because of this ragtag
group of misfits
that defended that city in that
outrageous, overwhelming odds.
So Andrew Jackson went on
to become a national hero,
even though he's kind
of an awful person.
They didn't have the
internet, so they
couldn't find out that he
was a racist promise-breaker.
He stiffed his
contractors, by the way.
He didn't pay any of
the freemen of color
even though he promised them.
But he became president anyway.
Edward Livingston, Saul Goodman,
became the Secretary of State.
And John Laffite was pardoned
from all of his previous crimes
he may have committed.
So he went from stealing
votes to stealing
the hearts of New Orleans'
beautiful married ladies.
He became a man about town,
sort of a local socialite.
Anyway, the lesson
from this story,
it's not about Andrew Jackson's
leadership and that speech,
let's get over our
differences and save the city.
And it's not exactly about
the British colonel's hubris
and actually this
really dumb approach
to fighting this battle.
But it's that in order
to beat the odds,
a team of people who are
all good at their jobs
and unified and
similar is not nearly
going to be as effective as
a team with the right kinds
of different ways of thinking
and working together,
the different perspectives and
heuristics that this ragtag
army taught each other,
the Choctaw Braves teaching
the Dirty Shirts how
to do guerrilla war
and assassinations, which
again this sort of ghastly.
It was fighting this
like an Indian skirmish.
It was the pirates
and their cannons
and the freemen of
color all combining
their different points
of view on war that
helped them win this battle.
And of course, war is
fought very differently now,
but at the time, this was very
innovative and groundbreaking.
So when Andrew Jackson says,
let's set aside our differences
and fight this
battle, he might say
or we might say some
things are more important
than our differences, saving
the city, our superordinate goal
that we're trying to achieve.
But I think this is an
example of something
that we all deep
down really know.
Maybe the important
thing is our differences,
and we should lean into that.
So that's what I got.
Thank you very much.
And I would love to answer any
questions with any little time
we have left.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Is that the microphone?
AUDIENCE: It is, yes.
So I guess I'll ask the
first question then.
Something that I've always
thought about is this--
and first of all, thank
you for coming by.
Always a pleasure.
In regards to the
culture, I kind of
feel like it's kind of a
contradiction, because we say,
hey, Eric, bring
yourself and everything
you are to our company, but
then adapt to this culture.
So how do you navigate
that acclimation period?
SHANE SNOW: Yeah, I think
that culture fit is actually
a fairly poisonous concept.
So there's research in the '70s
that they did that basically
determined that
we're the most happy
at work when we work with people
who have our same personality.
And for 40 years,
we've of conflated that
with being productive
and being good
at solving problems together.
Turns out that having
the same personality
is actually not very
good for becoming smarter
than the smartest
person in your group.
And being happy at work
actually can be at odds
with the thing that helps, which
is that cognitive friction.
So I think that
culture fit is actually
one of those things that
sounds like a good idea,
because we want to be happy.
We want to be comfortable.
We want to have peace.
But it's actually the
intellectual battle
that helps us to stretch
and to become better.
So I mean, I think
that culture add
is actually the thing that
we should be talking about,
and lots of people are
starting to talk about this.
But there is this
question of what
do we need to be
unified around, right?
If we lean into the
thing that, hey,
bringing different things that
are unique to the group is
actually what's going
to help the group,
if we combine in the right
ways and have the humility
and all that, but then what
keeps that group together?
And like in this story,
there was this purpose
that everyone had,
which was this land
that we want to protect.
Sort of like the aliens show
up to destroy the Earth,
we forget about our
borders, that sort of thing.
We don't always have
that in a company.
But ideally, you do
have a purpose of what
you're trying to accomplish.
I think Google has done really
well when the core values list
was basically don't be evil.
It's like, no duh, like
don't do wrong things.
And then everyone at Google for
years and years could recite,
our mission is to organize
the world's information.
That's a pretty good purpose
that if you're actually
down with and you leave
that path to getting there
as flexible as possible,
then it allows room
to be that sort
of band of misfits
as long as you're
trying to do that.
I think that purpose
is way more important
than like lists of behaviors
we want everyone to do, right?
And so I think to
some degree, Google
is a very good example
of having done that right
for many, many years.
Obviously no company is perfect,
and there's lots of stuff.
But I think the tendency we
have to say, great, you're
new to the group, we value you
being here, now be like this,
it just squashes the benefit
that we get out of it.
It's like telling people
to get off the mountain
and go on the other side.
So I think that's
something important
that we should talk about.
At my company, we actually
banned the word culture fit.
Any time someone said it,
we would use it as a--
we would sort of pause any
meeting and say, all right,
let's talk about how
we're not going to fit.
And I think that's actually
kind of important, easier
said than done,
but anyway, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SHANE SNOW: I sort of
like this microphone.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
What's the difference
between like,
I guess you said the poison of
culture fit versus you learning
because you don't know anything
about the corporate life,
like getting used to something
because you're learning it
versus you keeping
with yourself?
SHANE SNOW: Yeah, so you know
that whole mountain-range
cartoon diagram?
It also applies inside of
our own heads, too, right?
As we learn, as we gain
experiences and education
and work different
places, we're collecting
potentially different
perspectives and heuristics
that we can tap into.
So even in your own work,
it is valuable, I think,
to explore as much
of the mountain range
as possible, right?
So I think being curious
about things even
if you don't find them useful
can actually be really good.
You can draw lessons from them.
Einstein was notoriously sort
of a loner when he did his work.
He had like this rival that
pushed him, Niels Bohr.
But he had a really diverse
set of inputs into his process.
He was in a patent
office learning
about all these different kinds
of industries and inventions.
Certainly helped.
And he was curious about them.
But he also played the violin,
he was really into drama.
Those things all helped broaden
his potential zone of friction
inside his own head.
So I think you're new
to an organization,
actually learning how the
organization does function
is really important,
but resisting the urge
to have to fit and realizing
that if the organization is
smart, even if
it's not, what you
can bring that's outside of
the normal way of thinking
to provoke new ways of thinking,
even if what you're bringing
is not the best.
You're on a lower mountain peak.
Whatever you're
bringing can help
explore more of that range.
So I think that's important.
In the book I have
a couple of chapters
about that idea of what
often looks crazy or useless
can actually be really helpful
in solving problems, which
is an excuse for
including people who
are more novices
in a deliberation
process or
problem-solving process.
With the cops thing,
there's research
about how when you put an
old cop with a young cop,
sort of like a buddy
cop movie thing,
that that partnership
will do better,
just like when you put a male
cop and a female cop together.
All cops tend to have a
different set of perspectives
and heuristics, and new cops
tend to have a little bit more
of that either no, we
gotta do it by the book
or, well, why do we
have to do it that way?
And that actually helps
with that process.
Anyway, I'm kind of
rambling at this point,
but I think all this stuff
as a pragmatic excuse
for doing what's the
right thing to do,
which is including people in--
the more different
kinds of people
that we have working on things,
the better chance we have
of breaking through.
It's also a good moral choice.
Anyone else have a--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you talked a little
bit about like if you pass--
you had that graph
where it was like,
this is the area of destruction.
Do you have any tips
or recommendations
for how you prevent
from getting in that?
I mean, is it
possible that you have
too much cognitive diversity?
Or is there other things
that you do recommend
to not get into that area?
SHANE SNOW: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So is it possible to have
too much cognitive diversity?
You need cognitive
diversity that's relevant.
So like me being a pizza
driver when I'm age
16 might actually not be
a relevant perspective
to solving an algorithm
problem or something.
It might be.
You want to set yourself
up so you have the broadest
array of possibilities.
But some cognitive diversity
is not going to be relevant.
And I think often
we make decisions
on who to include in a
problem-solving process
or on a team based on who was
on the team last or who's here,
who's available,
or what's obvious.
And I do think that
there's a very good excuse
to include wildcards
and you should always
include people who are going
to be affected by solutions
to problems and all that.
But you can have too many people
sitting around a table coming
up with ideas, right?
It's actually more
ideal to have a series
of one-on-one processes
when you can amp up
the debate and the friction with
different people and it's safe
and all that.
But the other
thing that you were
asking about getting out
of the destruction zone
or avoiding that,
usually the problem
that most organizations have is
that you're so afraid of that
that you pipe down.
You quiet up.
You have what's called
organizational silence.
This is what kills mergers and
marriages and everything, is
when you stop talking about
things that are important,
because you're afraid
of the conflict.
But there's a few things, and
I get into this in the book.
There's a couple
of things that are
easy to do to reduce the
tension in our relationship
between people that have a
lot of cognitive diversity
and maybe that have fear of
their differences in general.
One of them is playing.
So it turns out that
play and humor simulates
the situation of anxiety.
But your brain knows
when you're playing
or when there's a joke
that it's not real
and it's not actually dangerous.
And so if you play
with a group of people,
you'll end up putting them in
your psychological in-group
after a while.
And they've done all sorts
of experiments in this.
Another thing that
I'm personally
really passionate
about is storytelling.
The neuroscience
of storytelling is
something that has been recently
dove into by neuroeconomists.
Basically the summary is when
you learn someone's story,
especially you learn something
vulnerable and emotional,
an emotion that you
can identify with,
your brain generates
oxytocin, which
is the empathy drug, which
makes you care about them.
And they've done
tons of experiments
that basically show--
and some companies
like BlackRock
have actually incorporated
this into a corporate setting.
If you and I don't
know each other
and maybe for
whatever reason we're
nervous about each other's very
different ideas or perspectives
or I grew up in a place where
you would be scared of me,
if I learn your story, then
I'll become more comfortable,
and we can actually have more
of that cognitive friction
between us, and it's safe.
So you build trust through
learning people's stories.
And you know that thing
in the "New York Times"
a couple of years
ago where it said
to fall in love with anyone, ask
each other these 30 questions?
Anyone see that?
This is a really a popular
story that basically is like,
if you go through these 30
questions with a stranger,
you will basically
fall in love with them
or you'll be much more likely
to have feelings for them.
All of those questions
are basically
asking you a series of
increasingly vulnerable stories
about yourself, what's
the last time you cried?
What's something that
you wish you would
have done in your childhood?
You can't share those kinds
of stories with people
without developing
empathy and trust.
And that allows
you to go further
in your intellectual
battle without it devolving
into something personal.
The Wright brothers,
they loved each other,
and they knew each other
and had this deep affection
for each other.
It allowed them to go further.
So things like that are
psychological tricks
that you can do.
Easier to do in a team setting,
in a small group of people,
or in a company then in like
society like on Facebook
or like, hey, let's
all play a game
so we can stop arguing about
Democrats versus Republicans.
Like that's a little bit harder.
But there's some real power
to learning people's stories.
But, yeah, I mean,
that's basically
the game that's
afoot, is how do we
keep our relationships
in that zone
without it getting personal?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Do you hear me?
OK, so speaking of
stories, I really
love the way you started with
a story and put everything
in that context.
SHANE SNOW: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Wanted to ask you
about that crucial step, which
is people need to
be flexible and be
able to change their opinion
in order for progress to exist.
So what would you
recommend doing in a set-up
where do you see that there is
resistance from certain people
that they don't want to do that?
And then what do you do?
SHANE SNOW: Yeah, so
I think if there's
one skill everyone
in the world could
learn that would make everything
better, like all of work
and all of society, it would
be intellectual humility.
And intellectual
humility is something
that philosophers have
talked about for a long time,
but it's only in
2017 that we could
actually-- we had an
assessment for measuring
intellectual humility.
And it breaks down
to a few categories.
So if you go to
shanesnow.com/IH,
you can take the actual test
that they developed and see
what areas you need to improve.
So for me, separating my ego
from my intellect is very hard.
If you convince me
I'm wrong, I will
be more likely than the average
person to revise my viewpoint.
But it will hurt
bad, so that makes
me harder to collaborate with.
So that's one thing.
If you're dealing
with someone who
you know is going
to be resistant,
there's a few tricks.
You want to prime them to not
get into personal battle mode
and to be in more
intellectual battle mode.
My favorite thing of
late is Ben Franklin
had this trick that he would do.
He knew most the time
he's the smartest
person he's interacting with.
But he also knew
that he's not going
to get better if he acted that
way and that he could be wrong.
So when he was going to express
an argument of something
that he felt very strongly about
or tried to persuade someone,
he'd always start
with, I could be wrong,
but-- and then he'd hit
him with the argument.
And what it does is
it primes that person
to feel like it's not
going to be personal
if they prove you wrong.
And they're less on their heels
when you start the argument.
He'd also shy away from using
absolutes, like it's always
or it's certainly or whatever.
So there's always
room for change.
But for him, it helped because
if you proved him wrong,
he was still right.
He could tell his ego,
I said I could be wrong,
and I was, so I'm right.
And there's stuff
like that you can do.
I just wrote a post
in my newsletter--
you can go to my
website and see it--
about a few other strategies
for that sort of thing,
keeping your identity small.
What are things that you can do
to not bring your personal ego
and identity into conversation.
It's hard to force
someone else to do that.
But the more that
you can get them
to see you as a human being and
separate your ideas from who
you are and see that
you're doing that with them
and that you're allowing them
the opportunity to change
your mind, that often rubs off.
Some people are not
going to do that,
and then you've got to
question, are they the kind
of people you want
to collaborate?
Maybe you just consult
them, get their input,
but you don't actually
work with them.
But there's a lot of
work to be done there.
But I that's the big challenge
that leaders have nowadays.
We have this idea of the
leader as the strong one who
doesn't change, that can take
the bullets and lead the army
or whatever.
The best leaders
are the ones that
are going to be willing
to change their minds
and to be humble, basically,
and not say, I'm the greatest
and I'm always right,
even though that's
the kind of people that we
tend to think of as leaders,
because that's who would help
us beat the saber tooth tigers
or whatever back in the day.
So, yeah, there's a lot
of work to be done there.
But I think that's
super important.
Thank you so much for coming
in and listening to this.
And if you end up cracking
open the book and reading it,
go to my website and tell
me what you thought of it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]